we have had so many amazing panelists on
the show comedians actors directors
musicians a couple Instagram kids but
you know one of my all-time favorite
guests is back on tonight he's a senator
who can summon Birds turns regular skin
and deliver spots and make socialist
rock hard
please welcome Bernie Sanders
[Applause]
it's a little bit of everything going on
here right now all right great
where's the microphone where are they
they woke me up with it
I think you're still waking up senator
Sanders how are you doing I got them a
little irregular which I hear is the new
regular focus on enough chitchat
Christopher I have news and it's a story
I got to tell you about because people
need the facts Millennials you've heard
of them they love avocados they eat them
for every meal they buy them instead of
houses they have even been known to
watch live streams of avocados turning
brown what what people do not realize
Christopher is that Millennials did not
invent avocado Pope's what are you
talking about Bernard hook whistle
effects the San Francisco Chronicle
published a recipe Barbara Coto post the
1927 that's the year that I graduated
from law school
it is avocado on toasted 90 years ago
this September this recipe proves that
Millennials are just taking things from
generations that came before them like
fedoras and crushing national debt by
the work that includes other trends like
ghosting in fact I goes to Jesus water
and then he wholly goes to me
okay it's a long story I don't want to
get into it Christopher also look I roll
a penny farthing bicycle back when it
was known as just a bicycle I was using
ammo he back when they were called
hieroglyphic
[Applause]